you
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us
communities in schools is a nonprofit
working across the country it provides
struggling students with everything from
food to academic support for the last
year the group has also been empowering
students through art that tells their
personal stories Jan Crawford spoke with
one recent middle school graduate whose
life was turned into a portrait the
Gunston middle school class of 2019
first Jim's al Huli this graduation
ceremony is just one chapter in a long
international journey I'm where as you
know II from Syria every day I would
hear like gunshots through the night
shams and his family fled the war
arriving in the United States four years
ago but it wasn't exactly what shams had
imagined I heard that sometimes it could
be like the place of freedom but then
like was kind of different in what way
what do you mean some people didn't
accept you into their groups and that
was really it was surprising for me
because I thought like everybody
accepted everybody and everybody likes
each other that was what you thought the
United States was like can you talk
about that that was like for you some
people were bullying me for not knowing
English that much and that really hurt
me sometimes and I didn't tell anybody
but then like when I learned to speak up
for myself I just tried to like talk to
them and like push them off and that
really helped after adjusting to life at
Gunston middle school in Northern
Virginia shams was accepted into the
community in schools what we were made
of program what did it mean to you it
meant a lot my mom was also super happy
and that really made me extra happy
because I would do anything to make my
mom happy
the program has shams to reflect on his
personal journey but say what's in her
boss he put together a collection of
items that told his story so my first
thing is a microphone the
it really describes how I learned to
speak up for myself I also have baseball
because I really like playing baseball
and you didn't have baseball Syria no I
didn't know what they saw was that box
traveled all the way from Virginia to
the San Francisco studio of pop artist
Jason Mercier known for his celebrity
murals mecir took shams assorted
keepsakes and turned them into a unified
portrait a lot of the portraits I do are
superficial and I know that somehow it's
more I don't know I guess it's more
personal and just hours before shams
graduation mecir met his subject for the
first time to reveal the final creation
I hope you like I love how you used
every single thing that I gave you and
as he heads into high school shem said
he hopes the program will help others
find their voice some kids might really
get bullied just because they speak a
different language or they practice a
different religion but it doesn't matter
what other people think about you it
really just matters what you think about
yourself for CBS this morning Jan
Crawford Arlington Virginia Crawford I
bow to you and shams and the artist I
mean it's such a special special
one-of-a-kind gift yeah and it seems
like such a sweet guy and any time you
hear it kids say I'd do anything to make
my mom happy yeah imagine Ella's mom for
you hope is that attempted to sell out
to pay for college
hold on to that pan that
yeah you're always holding on to that